ready ready okay all you girl you guys
we have a very exciting outfit of the
day today I have a special guest with me
Emily Chang from Bloomberg is
[Music]
here so what do you say to people who
think influencers don't have real jobs
yeah I think that's a pretty popular
sentiment I truly feel like it's 24
saath so I've doing it as a side hustle
for basically until this year in
February I was laid off so I kind of
took a month to think about like am I
going to do this full-time am I going to
give it a shot and it was actually
through the encouragement of my audience
that I they said take a risk on
[Music]
yourself the concept of someone
recommending something for you to buy
isn't exactly new but the professional
lifestyle influencer you've undoubtedly
seen online has only existed for the the
last 10 years or so that's thanks to
techsavvy affiliate networks like ltk
which have developed a way to cut online
creators in on the products they're
promoting and sell they have in 2022
$3.6 billion worth of merchandise was
sold through LT Case Technology alone I
was a 22-year-old girl who had a
personal shopping business I was living
at home eating my dad's cereal and I had
about $260 is doll in my bank account so
it was really only up from there I very
much needed this platform to work and
thank God it did when we launched ltk it
was all about monetizing blogs by taking
people shopping ltk is a three-sided
Marketplace we have creators who talk
about brands on the second side of our
Marketplace and then the consumers who
come shopping as a Creator if you're
accepted into ltk you're immediately in
a commercial relationship with 7,000
Brands so that's everyone from the big
French luxury Brands all the way down
through your corner market store
research for statista estimates the
amount paid to influencers in 2022 hit
some $16 billion last year that's
because brands have found that some
consumers are more willing to make
purchases from someone they follow
online versus being compelled by a
traditional ad SoftBank is betting big
on ltk approach pouring $300 million
into the company in 2021 what kind of
metrics do you get from ltk every
morning I check my analytics so you can
see how many times an item was clicked
on how many times someone bought it um
what the conversion rate on that is and
the brands also have access to that
which is really cool so you can look at
monthly analytics you can look at
year-over-year this month compared to
last month to see the growth of your
business the biggest development is
really what we're able now to do with AI
and ml the winners in this space win
based on their data Lake ours is bigger
than everyone we know what our creators
are talking about we know what consumers
are clicking on when a Creator is using
our tool they're opening up the Creator
side of the app they're uploading
content that they've created original
content and then they're captioning it
and sharing it out then once a shopper
finds it makes a purchase we're actually
notifying them the purchase was made
they're able to use our insights and
analytics Suites to actually understand
what content is converting what products
at what price point from where retailers
and then create more content that's more
targeted to what their customers want
from
them I've always wanted to have my own
business ever since I was a little girl
I wanted to have something and I feel
like I tried so many different things
that went nowhere but but I'm all about
failing forward this is the only
industry in which you see women
dominating and it's such a beautiful
thing for me to look across a room and
see other women again providing for
their families um creating content
that's helping other women it's a
beautiful thing ltk now has to compete
with other networks like shop style and
share aale and even companies as big as
Amazon which has its own influencer
program so how does ltk stand out there
are two words I want you to leave with
this conference thinking about and the
first one is community and the second is
curation when we started this business
blogging wasn't a part of common
vernacular while there are people who do
pieces of the ecosystem that we provide
for a Creator maybe they have some brand
campaigns or maybe they have a social
element I always tell our creators look
you are building an e-commerce Empire
all your
own now the algorithm is honestly Ever
Changing and I think it can definitely
take a toll on you um feeling really out
of control of how many people are
viewing things that day um how many
views that you may get on a post or
video so you really have to kind of
think of a way to kind of continue
posting and continue getting your
content out there so is there anything
that you'd like Instagram to
change I'd love them to go back to their
old
algorithm feel like I could do a cute
little outfit with this plaid coat and
the booties I'm obsessed with this I
know going to get a lot of wear out of
[Music]
thato